همم موضوع مهم جدا في هذه الحرب بسوق
الطاقه هو اهم متاثر بمجريات الحرب
والاكثر تاثيرا بالاستقرار همم وتاثرا
ايضا
في السوق العالمي وسلاسل توريد النفط
والغاز وكل هذه الامور الدول الاوروبيه
التي كانت تعتمد على روسيا بنسبه 40%
لتوفير اغازها وبعد الحرب شرعت سريعا
لتوفير مصادر بديله في السوق البديل كان
من موردين مثل النرويج والولايات المتحده
واذربيجان والجزائر وقطر روسيا بدورها
حولت منتوجها الى اسواق بديله كان للصين
النصيب الاكبر فيما يتعلق بنفس شكل خطوه
توضع السقف لسعر برميل النفط الروسي من
قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع
واستراليا وعطف الاخر صعوبه هذا القرار
على روسيا تكمن في خساره جزء من السوق
وتضرر سلاسل لتوريها حيث ان 90% من
شحناتها تنقل عبر شركات من مجموعه الدول
وعليه كان رد فعل موسكو بحظر توريد النفل
الدول التي شاركت في القرار ما يعني حرمان
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من 45% والسوق
الامريكي من 10% من الواردات النفطيه
روسيا بدورها حولت الصادرات مجددا الى
الشرق وزادت التصدير بنحو الثلثين تجاه
الاسواق الاسيويه خصوصا الصين والهند